lucie brin nous ouvre les portes du
centre d'appels de telles écoutes et
elle est née c'est dans cette modeste
pièce que des bénévoles font la
différence dans la vie de personnes en
détresse
vous savez que 55000 aînés au québec qui
ont personne aucun proche
aucun ami qui vit dans la solitude et
cette solitude fait des ravages
selon les plus récents chiffres de
l'association québécoise de prévention
du suicide
plus d'une quinzaine d'années âgé de 60
ans et plus
s'enlève la vie à tous les mois au
québec et ça ce sont les suicides
répertoriés parce qu'un aîné qu'on
retrouve chez lui comme c'est arrivé
récemment dans notre quartier 6 qui a
arrêté de manger ou de prendre sa
médication qui est décédé il ya pas un
corner prévenant qu'elle lui cibray est
convaincu que son organisme des côtes a
plus que jamais sa pertinence
comme le démontrent les 12 mai l'appel
qu'ils reçoivent annuellement
il ya des études récentes qui disent que
la solitude c'est pire que le tabagisme
c'est pire que la sédentarité
ça peut causer une mort prématurée il ya
des effets très néfastes beaucoup plus
grave qu'on pense l'elysée l'une des
soixante dix bénévoles de l'organisme
la retraitée a passé sa carrière au
mouvement desjardins à jongler avec les
chiffres
aujourd'hui elle dit qu'elle travaille
avec son coeur en prenant les appels de
gens en détresse
un à un les noms des gens qui veulent
mettre fin à leur vie des gens qui ont
que qui ont pas de solution des gens qui
voient pas la lumière au bout du tunnel
l'organisme est présentement à la
recherche de bénévoles qui auront une
formation de trois jours sur les côtes
active qui aide les gens à s'ouvrir
les ennemis ne veulent pas écouter leurs
enfants donc il nous confie à une
personne extérieure
enfin ce qu'ils n'ont pas dit c'est donc
ce groupe tissée serrée qui va tenter de
veiller sur les aînés dans le besoin
en jouant un peu le rôle d'ange gardien
en cette période des fêtes ici pascal
robidas radio-canada bon